this is me on my way out of the office
and this is my exact location as seen on
my colleagues phone who's tracking me in
fact right now he can see my every
movement as a leaf work walk to the
train station and head downtown
this is the kind of tracking not spy
apps and able in this case my colleague
followed my location using a standard
iPhone app called find my friends it's
meant for meeting people around the city
but it's one of many smartphone apps
that can be easily abused and turned
into spyware in fact according to one
study they are potentially thousands of
apps for Android and hundreds and at
those app store that could let someone
you know get access to your private
information without your knowledge the
legitimate apps so they can't just get
rid of them but there also can be
dangerous as dangerous as any other
spyware that's because they are
increasingly used to digitally stalk
someone often partners or ex partners
which experts say is a growing problem
around the world and often leads to
violence
my ex-boyfriend said that he would find
me anywhere I could go he said he knew
how to track me down allison is one of
many women who have experienced digital
stalking for security reasons she wants
us stay anonymous so Vivi enacted her
statement I went and stayed with friends
but he started showing up there that's
when I started to think that he had been
telling me the truth
that he could always find me the thing
that is most disturbing about it is not
understanding the limits of your abusers
power you don't know exactly what is
being spied on and you don't know what
has been compromised and when you don't
know then it feels like the abuser is
all-powerful like they must know
everything so I got really paranoid and
was always looking over my shoulder
and I couldn't be sure who to trust it
was a really bad time for me there are
also so-called stock aware or spyware
programs available outside the official
app stores the tech spying to the next
level
for $25 per month this app provides
remote access to nearly anything it can
even turn on the camera or listen in on
phone conversations stalker where is an
excellent tool for for domestic abusers
it is in fact advertised one of the
stock aware companies featured a photo
of a man holding a woman's wrist the
woman is looking down she has blood on
her face and a black eye and it's very
clear not only does this man abusing
this woman because ostensibly she has
cheated but that the company that is
selling this product is on the side of
the abuser installing stock aware on
someone's phone is often surprisingly
easy all the abuser needs is physical
access to the victims smartphone and the
passcode two things most partners or ex
partners already have most of the time
the app runs in the background and is
hard to detect
experts say digital stalking is a
growing problem a recent survey in
Australia found that nearly 20% of
domestic abuse victims were tracked
using GPS and recent data leaks from
stock of our companies revealed hundreds
of thousands of clients but how is this
legal in the first place so these
companies they have Terms of Service
that say please don't install this they
stop on a device you don't have legal
permission to this is designed for
monitoring your workers on phones that
you've purchased for them or your kids
on phones and you purchase for them you
have the legal right to but then
throughout their website you'll see you
know how to catch your partner cheating
how to install this app without anybody
knowing experts would like to see tech
companies as well as law enforcement
take the problem more seriously in the
meantime they have some tips on how to
protect yourself
one of the things that you should really
do is use a password manager to make
sure that all of your passwords are
strong and unique and you should turn on
the highest level of two-factor
authentication that you're comfortable
using for all of your accounts this will
be enough to lock an abuser out of out
of most things when I learned I was
being stalked by him through my phone
suddenly everything made more sense I
don't even trust my new phone now but at
least I know what to look for